Doors open at 4 o'clock on Thanksgiving Day?
Online sales beginning the Monday before Thanksgiving?
Christmas merchandise in stores in September?
Thanksgiving; it's one part "Thanks", one part "Giving."
But is this message being eclipsed by Black Friday commercialism?
I'm Doug Matthews, an allrecipes community member.
Last November, I wrote a blog post on allrecipes.com...
...requesting that people give Thanksgiving its due.
The post was titled "Respect the Bird".
This year, allrecipes is taking Respect the Bird to a whole new level.
And we want you to join the fight to take back Thanksgiving.
Here's how you can respect the bird this November.
There's strength in numbers. So first, take the pledge to be thankful.
Share the message.
And finally, follow along at respecthebird.com on Twitter and on Facebook.
We want you to join us at the table this year...
...instead of spending the day shopping for cyber deals.
So ignore the hype, embrace the holiday and most of all, Respect the Bird.